autant peau c'est le premier club des
partenaires organisé par l'association
anima sauce dans le cadre du festival
pulsations un événement artistique et
musical à venir sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
la rencontre entre les partenaires et
l'association a pris place à lille de
loisirs dimanche 13 juin au programme
échange présentation du lieu du festival
ou encore concerts objectif fédérer une
communauté et maintenir le lien jusqu'au
festival
l'idée là c'était d'avoir un événement
qu'ils soient récurrents dont d'avoir au
moins trois rendez-vous dans l'année
avec tous les partenaires soient des
partenaires qu'on a déjà contacté soit
des gens qu'on va rencontrer pour créer
une communauté autour du festival que
c'est une communauté avec des
institutionnels des associatifs des
individuels du territoire de 50 ans de
la première édition du festival
pulsations est prévue à l'horizon 2023
partenaires du projet et c'est l'espace
événementiel de ligne de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines qui
accueillera l'événement est donc c'est
un superbe espace de 4 hectares plein
air a clôturé avec des sanitaires des
branchements haïti et rick un terrain de
sport de plage et s'est parfaitement
adapté à l'accueil d'un festival de ce
type il y aura une partie et d'accueil
du public sous la partie du dôme et
ensuite tout le festival se fera à
l'extérieur donc autour du bassin avec
des poutres qu'avec de la restauration
de la boisson pour retrouver un village
artistique et solidaire avec des
ateliers participatifs collaboratif avec
une ou deux scènes musicales avec une
programmation d'artistes professionnels
d'artistes émergents du territoire et
puis aussi du spectacle vivant
au total une cinquantaine de personnes
étaient présentes pour cette première
rencontre
un prochain club des partenaires
pourrait se tenir au mois d'octobre
d'autres performances artistiques auront
lieu sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines pour faire patienter
jusqu'au festival